so Robert obviously a pilot yourself how  did that experience help you when you're  making fly I was able to bring a real  authenticity to the to the plane crash  that helped out quite a bit a lot i'm  working with gentle as well for the  first time what was that lying that was  great he's a great actor you know  everything he does is fantastic it was a  real was a thrill every day what was  your flight experience is either as a  pilot or a passenger van have you had  worse ones you can tell us about no  thank goodness I want to experience my  flight problems in in the movies night  in the air and finally begin just ask  you very quickly I mean everyone's  talking about Who Framed Roger Rabbit  where there's going to be a sequel can  we look for words that coming from you  sometime soon no there won't be a sequel  yes thank you and say that  you